one of nevada's very own recently won a
very prestigious scholarship allowing
her to fight for others suffering from
substance abuse 23 year old kelsey
matthews is a junior at unlv not only is
she already holding a pageant title but
now she's a truman scholar victoria saha
has the story
out of 705 candidates nationwide one
unlv student was given an opportunity of
a lifetime hear how this unlv rebel
overcame life's biggest obstacles to now
help others in her community kelsey
matthews already had her hands full as
miss nevada volunteer a pageant that
focuses on community service for me
having the crown allows for a greater
sphere of influence her service is
focused on those suffering from drug
addiction spending her time at
crossroads recovery and vegas stronger a
passion driven from witnessing drug
abuse first hand and i was kind of my
mother's mother i kind of lived my life
as far as is she going to die today
tomorrow or next week matthews woke up
one morning in 2016 to find her mom dead
from an accidental overdose it was a
little bit of relief there because i
knew that
she wasn't suffering anymore while
balancing a crown school and volunteer
work this social work major applied to
the truman scholarship which would grant
recipients 30 thousand dollars for grad
school and on wednesday she got the news
she was waiting for
this moment of someone who grew up in a
less than ideal situation and who barely
graduated high school all these years
later to come and be told you're a
truman scholar with the help of this
scholarship matthews hopes to go into
law and focus on public policy victoria
zaha live local now